where you going hey I'm Stefon Diggs I'm
here to our new studio getting ready to
do some yoga with my girl Claire you
know you're living more flexible so see
how it helps me on the football fair
let's go
Stephan Claire nice to meet you we've
had to do yoga and shoes I mean you
could probably make this happen
why oh the appealing at this point yeah
right now I'm trying to get a little bit
more flexible my hips are low tight here
yoga helps with that mobility but we're
also gonna try to not work too terribly
emotional flexibility if you get too
loose you won't be as quick then are you
ready to get started
sure and Haley already on the breathing
right through your nose lift your
shoulders up and then as you exhale roll
your shoulder blades back and down
tabletop position the wrists are under
the shoulders and these are under the
hips okay and just kind of cow just
working your spine back big inhale lift
the arms up come with me sorry okay
[Music]
a super leap into my world I got a
couple of days plans I already believe
that like yoga and football have a
relationship that it's like goes really
well together I think all football
players should do yoga and it was it was
really nice to see that he wasn't a
beginner my first time meeting her I was
a little scared of her a little bit she
has too much experience for me but she
taught me a couple we're gonna working
some brows I don't know how good
Jarrah's would be and I got my wish list
so if you're out here Kali gagging I
think you need some what about a
beginning all right as the combination
between speed you know it's all about
putting speed impression on people and
just brakes and catching them up I want
you to play the ecstasy that's one of
the most important positions this is a
go route he's going straight as fast as
you can it doesn't require any braking
and I get his catch the wall
I quit you on a slant I'm using tip 92
steps
brake 45 degrees catch the ball keep
running score out slant we're gonna come
on it too high
we're together